for the tampa bay rays here tonight it
will be right-hander michael walka
making his 19th start of the season 24th
overall appearance the record two and
four era 5.70
the 02 lifted back into center field
here meyer is going to be there to make
the catch one away
and swing again to miss you a changeup
and buxton is out on strikes for out
number two here in the first here's
jorge polanco no score two outs top of
the first and this one hit high in the
air to right field and this ball is deep
and this ball is gone a home run for
jorge polanco one-nothing minnesota
twins well he spit on the one that was
close and then he got the heater he
wanted and jorge polanco deposits it in
the right field seats and for jorge
polanco a career high 25th home run of
the year he likes hitting against
tropicana in nine games now ten games
chris he's hit seven home runs
a one-one pitch and this one's in the
air to right but i think he's going to
stay in the park backing up but it is a
rosary onto the warning track and he
makes the catch and that will retire the
side randy dobneck is making his first
start since june 19th welcome back randy
dobneck
simmons flips one away
another ground ball
this one to polanco two away
three ground ball outs
dobneck with a really efficient first
inning there's austin meadows to lead
off the second for the raise
1-1 pitch meadows takes the other way
that's going to drop in
and bound toward the line meadows is
going to wind up at second
gordon a little tentative out there in
left field and then that ball took a
bounce away from it
so an extra bait's hit for meadows
brings the ball bounding away over to
third base goes meadows and the raves
have a runner there with nobody out now
broken bat a roller up the first base
side throw to the plate's not going to
be in time
cenote came in and decided to go to the
plate
and the ray is going to run
and a base runner so a runner at first
still nobody out
and here's kermeyer shooting one up the
gap into right center field gonna roll
all the way to the wall the rose arena
around third he will score
kirby's gonna go to third he will stop
there
stand up triple and the rays grab the
lead
this slider right into the swing and he
just sweeps it
deep out into right center field
and he got it into the gap he got it to
the wall you knew rosarina was going to
walk home could you keep kiermeier at
third
well they were able to do that so he's
in there with his third triple of the
year
that's a chop to short no chance at the
plate the run will score simmons
goes to first to get the out and the
rays make it a three-run inning
lead by two three to one as we go to the
third inning
ground ball third tough play
long throw and the one hopper
nicely done to get simmons
wendell to diaz
and a cut in the miss
boy walker has taken care of him twice
six pitches total
it is here's buxton sending a fly ball
into center field
here meyer
will put this one away and a quick one
two three inning
we go to the home half of hitting three
and joey wendell
leads off and
sends this one into left-center field
that'll be cut off by gordon big turn
and joey wendell holds it first
with the lead off single lead off made
on for the raise how can the race get
nelson cruz going
that's gonna
go for extra bases
go all the way to the wall
wendell's gonna score
crews will wind up at second
and the rays make it 4-1
you know what this is another fastball
another sinker that's left out over the
plate you see how it flattens out it
becomes very hittable and then buxton
right here just making that calculation
to to give up on it and play it off the
carrum as opposed to trying to cut it
off
and joey wendell hustling all the way
around for another run for the raise
austin meadows
and that's a base hit
that will get the run home crews being
waved around by linares on the single by
meadows
swinging 3-0
it's down 5-1
rbi number 94 from edm
5-1 ray's lead we go to the fourth
and walka strikes him out
and a nice job right there changing
speeds
i love that change up tonight i love
walking out there attacking the strike
zone with the fastball
good velocity on that pitch moving it
around and then this turning over that
change up getting some good late finish
and he got him oh my
he got him looking strike three called
is that
right there an idea of a pitcher who
knows exactly what he wants to do you
saw all the signs that he shook off to
get to that hook and then he dropped a
beauty right on the edge
the shot back into straight away center
field
keermeyer is going to be there and he
takes care of that
a one two three four then the raise will
send up francisco mejia
hits that ball well to center field
bucks and tracking back on the track
reaches up jumps up makes the catch not
home run distance but buxton
until he got back there left the turf
onto the warning track put his right
hand out
and feeling for the wall
took another step
and then left his feet
jumped up caught it nice little play
there by byron bucksman michael walker
working into the fifth inning there's a
swing and a miss
he struck him out so good job by waka
to come back from 3-0 and strike out
sano
and he gets it
six strikeout for waka here and now it's
12 in a row
jeff is now over his last 12 and just
three for his last 33
and jeffers with a drive to left
back
and gone a home run for ryan jeffers his
12th of the year and that breaks a
string of 11 straight outs recorded by
michael walker that was a change-up down
in the strike zone that ball jumped off
his bat that was that was gone from the
moment he made contact nice swing ryan
jefferson we haven't seen the twins have
too much success with michael walker's
change up tonight do you see that one in
a good spot but jeffers drops the head
down and puts a really nice swing on it
twitch down five to two here comes the
tip of a raise there's a drive to right
field and kepler picks it off the rug
before it hit the rug nice play by max
kepler for out number two
very nice catch for out number two
don back now has sent down eight men in
a row
over the mile but right two simmons
had a rough second and third inning but
he sent down nine men in a row randy
dodnak is back out for the seventh
dominic out there there's another ground
ball
and that's now 13 in a row for landon
two hops to snow there's dobneck on the
bag
is that
layton is out in ground ball after
ground ball after ground ball low
quickly retired
and there's now been 15 straight set
down by randy dobneck
has come through time and time again for
minnesota and they need him once more
still on the left field line chased by
meadows and wendell and that's a fair
ball
and by meadows
and with two outs off with the crack of
the bat a rise will score
and a really bad misplay in left field
by austin meadows off the bat of jorge
polanco to knock in his 80th run of the
year a new career high and the twins
trail it five to three and it's a
two-run game with andrew ketrich getting
the call the fourth pitcher of this game
for the rays
kepler sends a fly ball
into right center and margaux is waiting
one away
swinging in the midst to know a big cut
on the slider
he is out number two
and a way van a mess that's gonna do it
jeffers
out on strikes and the razor winners
it's a 5-3 final
the rays take the
first game of this series
you